do you know what that means steve can be
one of those nine seven puerto rico
oh
no i just see them because you know the
porn
they say that oh
i just want to see what steve's
searching for no you don't
[Music]
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
sony's to stuff that yeah man
i committed to this he gets stuck yeah
baby
and some cranberries
now did you have that just sitting
around what are you talking about like
do you have like a like you're like
batman you know what i mean like you're
gonna this is from home yeah like you
have like i assume you have the cone and
right right at home no you're like
someone say thanksgiving yeah he has
like a bookshelf he just goes
and it's just like
no i don't have that it's just like
dumbass costumes
now i would assume that's a turkey
because it's brown because it looks very
chicken-ish yeah
uh it's brown that'd be turkey because
chickens are white yeah i guess it
doesn't really have like a goblin this
is a bird oh there it is
oh
oh the trojan helmet down the front
that turkey trojan helmet
yeah it's a fun it's a fun day today
yeah today is thanksgiving it is now
demeanor look like uh like we're witches
that yeah are confused with our pronouns
harry potter because these these hats
are very witchy
is it pointy is mine pointy because
yeah we look like you look like dr seuss
yeah but like if he didn't go to school
you know what i mean yeah mr sue yeah
he's like just yeah he's not a yeah he's
mr seuss yeah eric looks like he gives
tours at disneyland of mickey mouse
i'm the dude on the bus like you know
to your right we have
steve and his chicken outfit yeah
yeah steve cute little turkey
your lucky feels not here theo's not
here yeah man let's let's to facetime
him yeah yeah get him on camera yeah
let's do a little facetime
to be honest and he told me i can see
this i'm not speaking out turn theo's
just he needs a break a break yeah i
mean he's more breaks anybody i know
yeah we're not better i do
seven shows and i tour but theo needs a
break
no you listen you know everyone knows
theo struggle with you know mental
health and [ __ ] like that that's fine
that's fine let him do his thing man
yeah but he's running out of vacation
days i'll tell you that much yeah i'm
the one that runs his ship and he you
run out of vacation days you feel me do
we got to go to hr yeah and you're
looking at hr right here yeah yeah i
don't know if you get too many paid
vacation days
you ain't lying i didn't think about
that
don't should run out i don't know if
this counts as attendance
uh
he's looking cute what a handsome dude
look at this handsome guy's hair's
getting long man yeah you've been
hanging with kid rock too much i haven't
i haven't even watched this yet so i'm
not sure what he says
what's up guys uh
my name is theo i am a long time fan of
the show love you guys eric stevie
derrick cat
brandon
um
nick
uh
spleen whatever that kid's name is
spleen boy or whatever
anyway king or sing it
uh
uh around the holidays letting white
people cook
kenyat or sting it um
thanksgiving special episode the fact
that he thinks
white people don't cook or shouldn't
cook is the real problem right here
yeah
yeah just cause your mom can't cook
david lucas has a great joke about uh
white people's thanksgiving i won't ruin
his joke he's still oh that he has a bit
of it's so [ __ ] funny yeah did you
guys have shows them the weekend yeah i
was just in miami oh how was miami yeah
miami was i think great club right yeah
it's a big club it was nice but it was
just i think that like going into the
holiday weekend tough it was tough
because people are traveling there yeah
it was tough
but it's a nice little area where it is
the dude was cool yeah i joined a good
running club right now what was the name
of the club
i went to tempe yeah i was oh dude i got
it i had it any fans told me too yeah
yeah yeah people hit me myself man what
do you mean you redeemed yourself
because that's the last
oh i did the cowboy wrap seven years ago
i used to work there as a food runner
you didn't bring a cowboy rap back so we
did a q a at the end and someone called
me out on it yeah we did it like at the
end uh you did it at the you know just i
already finished my set oh yeah dude i
did did it okay though i did okay
jeremiah told me he did really well and
then fans tell me like dude stevie was
great yeah i was you know he helped me
out a lot you know what it is do you
feel good yeah i feel good but i'm
addicted to
the adrenaline yeah of course is this
that you i didn't change there's this
adrenaline yeah man it's like a drug to
me chasing that dragon let's see the
king of the things the king in the sting
tour is
you know going to happen huh we got to
get it going that might happen it could
happen really
you know how when people like you know
those award shows and they go you know
uh such and such couldn't be here yeah
we have a video that's how we're gonna
be
uh you know and his behalf that's why
we'll do it is that a possibility though
for real for sure yeah getting let's get
like a
we'll do like you know a few cities yeah
though that's a whole different thing
though like that's easier what do you
mean mc you introdu you do a one joke
bring up the next
comic
come back out one joke a lot of energy
so you have energy so it's just like you
got to keep the show the the
energy up yeah okay
i haven't done it maybe i could practice
doing that [ __ ] turkey outfit man
you're a cute [ __ ] turkey man
what's everybody doing for uh
thanksgiving uh i don't know uh uh
hashtag no racist uh chen stevie here we
go again you guys do thanksgiving or
there's like a duck thing where every
year every year stevie everywhere do you
think we're eating dogs
no yeah
for sure duck right yeah like duck
because like it's not like turkeys are
like
they're not they're not roaming around
[ __ ] asia dude koreans eat turkeys
yeah we do american style thanksgiving
we just add a little bit of korean
ingredients cranberry
it's actually better yeah it's way
better to go to like asia
yeah because you they have all the same
stuff but then they also going to have
like you know sauce
right
like all the other stuff
when you say they have better
thanksgiving than white people you'd
never been a real white person's house
yes i have have you yes i have
what white person i'll tell you no no i
you know you don't you have to i have to
tell you all the white people i know i
know all of us
i know all right first of all we know
you're gonna have a fancy ass rich
thanksgiving
that's what you're gonna have by rich
thanks if you mean have turkey and
stuffing yeah oh here we go you know
he's going to have servants you know
what i mean people like runners but like
mr shaw but can i get you more can i get
you some more what what what
little english boys in but what white
person's house did it it wasn't great
through my whole life i've been to all
different types of things you've been
like down south where they have the
stuffing and the cornbread yes i've been
like like real yeah i've been to like
super black
those are me thanksgivings yeah yeah you
got like it's everybody puts their own
flavor on it the most twist on it yeah
the most bland is like yeah just like
super white if it's a basic white person
yeah what makes a whiteboard because
they don't use spices and like it's
super it's playing no suck oh no don't
they'll suck you need some seasoning in
there no but white people come on yeah
rachel ray
rachel ray for thanksgiving she's white
yeah they put a lot of butter on stuff
oh no that's their favorite agreement
yeah but they have all the necessities
they got the stuffing the corn yeah so
what are you doing since we i know
because i know we didn't get an invite
nobody here got an invite over to the
the shop everyone have their own [ __ ]
going well you know you don't know until
you ask oh that's fair you know you
could have been like hey guys we're
having a king in the state i mean we're
at capacity but that's fair oh here we
go
there it is there's no way
come on
capacity
man sorry yeah my girl's worried about
kovid so
i'm worried about coaching yeah yeah you
gotta show your cards at the door you
know how it goes man who's not showing
up how many no you know what it is is my
girl is like super mixing like born
raised in guadalajara so they don't
really [ __ ] with thanksgiving but you
know i grew up thinks it was a big deal
where it's turkey or ham and stuff and
cranberry and the the gravy and the corn
and then we watch football right
you know in my family's life so it's me
and a bunch of mexicans man that's fine
no i shoved that [ __ ] white turkey
down their throat yeah i cook i don't
use the gravy cooking yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i keep it super white we watch
football super so me and eric could go
sure
come over for sure of course open invite
man come on over here
bring your girl bring your fiance
though don't come without a dish though
oh it's a potluck don't come out with it
i don't know and don't bring it with a
big appetite yeah like a pumpkin pie i
could bring a pumpkin pie that's fine
from the store that's fine okay from the
store are they going
yeah bring something korean no no are
they were they initially invited i mean
we're hearing it for the first time
right now
crying over the turkey [ __ ] i was like
you're bringing this party
he would have been doing a solo episode
just yeah just yeah
crying he was looking over at boston
imagining like a cartoon
yeah i keep him away from boston man
holy [ __ ] it's almost the holidays
it's thanksgiving this week and then
soon
you'll see
christmas is creeping up and for the
holidays my friends at movement the
original watch brand to break all the
rules start by two college dropouts all
right they don't want you to overpay for
a nice watch and they got you covered
this holiday season and they're making
it super easy to give beautiful curated
gift boxes for him and her all right
free and quick shipping right to your
door just in time for the holidays
movement watches are designed in-house
and are super sleek clean won't break
the bank since they start just 95
buckaroos great for dads brothers
boyfriends husbands whatever it is
movement got you covered man movement
has sold almost 2 million watches
worldwide in over 160 countries people
love them i love them i love the metal
band watches they're super sleek and win
business
casual whatever it is you had a fancy
dinner or you're just hanging out with
your bros i love the sleek watches that
they provide man go to
mvmt.com cats that's
mvmt.com cats join the movement holidays
coming up man a lot of y'all got some
men's and some women's out there and you
get them gifts and you're panicking you
don't know what you're gonna do
well
this hypebeast pilgrim here got you
covered man all right and listen you
need fine jewelry that's right you need
fine drilling but you need in two days
shipping that's where my friends that
blue now got you covered man bluenow.com
the original online jeweler to high co
high income adults all right primary
males 25 or plus looking to get engaged
give the fine jewelry to your men's or
your women's whatever it is man blue
now.com can you can celebrate all the
special moments in life we're talking
christmas thanksgiving new years
hanukkah whatever it is we got the
perfect piece of jewelry for you man
they got quite the selection we have
preset diamonds gemstone jewelry blue
now offers endless options ready to ship
the same day man all right we got you
man and also each dime is gia graded
which allows you to view the unique
qualities of the carrots way and how
much it weighs it's color it's cut be
confident what you're buying man because
quality is key all right so make the
season shine with jewelry from
bluenow.com shop this week and take
advantage of the black friday sale with
the select jewelry up to 50 off wow 50
off plus now through christmas enjoy
free two-day shipping so if you're if
you procrastinate like me that two-day
shipping is clutch and as always every
blue now order is insured ships free and
arrives in discrete packaging that won't
give it away man you don't want to give
away your gift surprise or herm all
right go to bluenow.com get your forever
piece
i was trying to get uh uh us catered and
i was i had a hot lead on this company
it's called west of new orleans ooh
that's good look at this menu he makes
turkey stuffed with
crawfish it's like a creole take on
thanksgiving i thought it was like the
perfect thing but he just like around
thanksgiving this is a busy time but
after after christmas we're gonna get a
meal in here from marcus from west of
new orleans all right i like it
well hold on but why answer them
for the christmas tree because like this
is this six weeks this is his busy time
he's already saw his money yeah you know
he don't need to do free [ __ ] right now
if you want to pay him we can definitely
get a christmas meal too but yeah we'll
pay him get a christmas me i'm not
trying to eat this [ __ ] in february
off season i mean kind of he's gonna be
all tired everything's half-assed yeah
he's gonna be fat from his christmas
yeah that beef tenderloin with the
horseradish
nutty rum cake roasted garlic mash stop
bourbon bread six cheese what how many
cheeses are there any time they say six
cheese like how many cheese oh it means
cheese is too many cheeses
because i'm a cheese connoisseur i beat
them i beat them you know about cheese
we had a name you know
horror movies all right we did name game
cheeses
you are white
yeah so still man so we went hard in the
painting yeah but it lasts about an hour
that's about an hour going through after
grier and monster i'm out
you know
but as far as pie everyone basic basic
[ __ ] in here everyone goes uh pumpkin
pie yeah well what do you what what's
more than that pecan pizza peacock with
a nice dark roast coffee are you going
to have that in your house sure am all
right let's go
i'll pick you up steve
come on down come on down yeah we just
we'll just never get the address so
where is it you're not going over
bobby's well they didn't invite me
[Laughter]
what yeah not yet are you kidding me
yeah i think uh holiday is the most time
for if you're like a sad panda like you
suffer from depression i think holidays
really triggers yes yes yes
it actually really does my good good
friend who's like a brother to me you
know it's like any time the holidays
would come it would always be a
nightmare because it was like his mother
died you know what i mean and so then
those kind of things
that's when you're lacking things that's
when you're missing that thing that you
know it's about hollywood yeah it's
probably family people so it's like it
reminds me of that yeah
yeah and also if you're gonna die you
gotta hold off to january first man
you gotta pull through and wait yeah
because oh you're gonna [ __ ] up the
holidays for
everybody you know what i'm saying oh
yeah it sucks if you die during the
holidays yeah cause then every year
you're just reminded it's like an
anniversary yeah it's like merry
christmas and let's light a candle for
grandma i didn't tell the husband yeah i
keep that [ __ ] on life support to the
first for me yeah i want the kids to
[ __ ] out their christmas do people spend
holidays alone that's sad if you're
alone
like let's say
on thanksgiving day it doesn't have to
be sad yeah you should just like that's
when you go you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna order a meal from this place and
you know it's usually chinese yeah you
could sit in front of their open like
that you know they don't give a [ __ ]
about
somebody's struggling and give them an
invite brendan
i i always do that steal i invite him to
every single family fun every cuz he he
can't be sad around those kids you don't
have time
they put him through the [ __ ] run
my first uh christmas in la 2014 uh i've
told brendan this and actually him a
little bit uh stevie but i uh
intentionally moved out here was living
in my car yeah
it was it was like super exciting i like
it wasn't sad at all until was it super
exciting it was it was at what are you
just trying to you were trying to fool
yourself no it's not like hustle were
you in your car like
i kind of was until christmas and then i
got like of course super sad and almost
drove back and gave up on my dreams but
yeah look at you now someone convinced
me to stick it out like
like when you needed to like for me you
were in the car when it was time to go
take a [ __ ] or like take a shower taco
bell doug before i left minnesota i got
a gym membership uh any la fitness
shower whatever it was all planned it
was all planned oh you worked that's it
you worked that out yeah you did look at
you now i was gonna do 24-hour fitness
but yeah i was reading a lot of blogs
that said those are gay meet up places
yeah that's steam room you get [ __ ]
yeah oh they'll get bonus they'll suck
you up
you can't see in there don't look at
your butt so it's not a game if you
can't see hold on a second
we need to
we need to unpack what he just said if
it's over 110 it ain't gay
i don't know how he knows but from what
i've read it's right yeah i know that
you can't see your butt
jerk off your butt yeah i remember going
to the korean spa
you know did you go to that we spa
the one on olympic though it must be we
right yeah i went to the weekend
so like they have this huge hot tub so
i'm just in the hot tub i get in you
know i'm there you naked but ass [ __ ]
have to be
i look over
and
a dude is sitting on the edge of the
pool
he's just a red eagle and another dude
is just examining his dick you know what
i mean just like wow blah blah blah
okay they're a little too comfortable
here's a super comfortable here's a
little pro tip for you even if you have
an average sized dick you go to that wii
spot you got to be naked and it is what
it is fellas i'm not saying anything
against asians there's a lot of small
addictions
you go in there bro i spelled it like
dirt you're not saying i felt like dirk
diggler in that [ __ ] i was like what's
up
super comfortable i remember
it was in there and this this okay guys
these two asian guys were scrubbing each
other's back yeah yeah like the guy was
like you know bent over another guy had
like this thing and he was just my
rubbish my thing is though that's not
gay like if you're so comfortable you
know what i'm saying is
there's a code of ethics and there's
none of that behavior it's just straight
shooters there right yeah
i'm sure they're the most yeah they're
shooting steve yeah
behavior doesn't exist there's a huge
stigma yeah for koreans
that's the thing that's why i was
walking down my big dick because
[Laughter]
i was going around my big dick because
this is where we show it it's just like
a picture pops up right here i was
walking around my big dick because i
didn't i didn't get any gay vibes
you know you don't like car shows like
you have a badass car you'd bring your
car that's how i was at the show like i
brought the phone you're the man yeah
and everyone's like oh let me touch it
and then we're listening it wasn't gay
they're taking pictures bite and [ __ ] i
saw a korean man in this spot he had a
pretty big dick
yeah they exist they're they're he stood
out most of them are fat they're like
they're like this guy was skinny dude
and it was losing at girth yeah girth
too i see i've seen here steve's
measuring sticks
you got some girth too huh enough on the
tr
we're gonna talk more about this now
why do you think i have a baby baby i
know i'm a pilgrim oh
you need the others half out here
you need the other stuff it looks like a
big baby
oh you gotta oh you got the
this is a
costume for eight-year-olds uh so it the
whole thing didn't fit last second i
feel you i see you bailed on the pilgrim
hat you just got me out here on my own
i just wanted a variety
uh enough with the turkey gobbler talk
chin has a leprechaun hat on
i don't know what my house is on the
verge of racist
you can tell chin has a whole thing
about being sort of stylish because you
don't have the hat on the tailgate i got
to touch a little bit
the camera's right there
it's a little bit
chin smooth over there and then
literally kyle's here and when i saw it
was like man
it looks crazy yeah he looks like
pocahontas stuff
a little bit with a beard
the endangeredness day or whatever the
[ __ ] you know tomorrow or yeah tomorrow
yeah indigenous people and you know in
schools in l.a they don't uh they don't
really teach you about the pilgrims all
that [ __ ] they go in on the indians
well they don't want to they don't want
to teach about how the pilgrims were you
know coming in and taking land it wasn't
theirs and that's history though man
yeah that's what they did back in the
day oh yeah and then they apologized and
they all had a nice meal yeah we gave
them turkey yeah that's what we wanted
to say history's written by history is
written by the victor they always say
oh my bad we keep winning you know what
i'm saying here we go uh what do you got
nick
smooth transition let's see what this
guy has
brendan theo stevie eric
all the homies in that black and white
booth thanksgiving's here i got a debate
club for you
do you host that hitter at your pad
or do you
tag along at someone else's house
gang gang buzz buzz i think we know
i prefer
i prefer
it depends on your place
so if you have a nice place
and you like sharing your nice place
then yeah have it at your place but like
if you have friends who got like got it
going on i prefer to go there
yeah if someone does it right like like
don't have me over in half ass right
yeah
actually last year was the first year i
ever like cooked myself
i made a turkey and i had like a couple
of friends come over another cup it
feels good doesn't it i was like oh man
i i was like it's great now i got this
traeger grill this smoker yeah and i'm
smoking that turkey i'm not going to do
it this year because it's part of that
turkey you know you got to do it yeah
you ever people are deep frying they do
all kind of stuff people be dying do you
find those but like if you have somebody
in your life that is into like that
they're really into cooking and that you
want to go there you want to go
someplace where you feel like a family
vibe and then so it just depends if
you're going to create the family vibe
at your place have it at your place but
i like going to that place that you know
there's always that person who's like
you coming over yeah they're all about
it yeah they're all about it so yeah i
make a mean gravy so i force everybody
uh eat my gravy what's so special about
your gravy i learned it from my grandma
i make it from the i make it from the
the from the broth from the turkey yeah
yeah it's homemade [ __ ] that [ __ ] get up
ralph stevie i know i know but are you
supposed to put the turkey in the oven
that's the only way to do it right no
people deep frying you put it in above
him
to me i think smoked her he's the best
what he sucks in general yeah it does i
like turkey it's really hard it's really
hard
juicy and tender like it's the worst
white meat yeah and i like calling
what's smoking it what is that smoking
it well it's just looking the it's the
heat from the when you keep it closed
the heat from the smoke gets in the meat
yeah that's why you get like you have
like certain types of like wood that's
like that has like you know mesquite or
yeah
all those chips yeah that's what i have
i have a thing we have to put like
shit's tasty yeah it makes it really
nice [ __ ] maybe we should go over
[ __ ] eric's the deep fried was
dangerous though that's what's he doing
because it's basically like a ball of
ice and we put it in there the it'll
[ __ ] it kills people it blows up
houses and [ __ ] every year every year
people get [ __ ] up what are they doing
right there what is that just showing
examples of how a lot of college kids
get [ __ ] up off it but it turns into
basically a missile
leave that thing look at that [ __ ]
and these are these are firefighters in
there
look at this
that is crazy oh my god yeah basically a
little missile yeah little meat missile
yeah right next to his garage eric
growing up would you would your mom do
uh we didn't do thanksgiving like that
we always went someplace yeah yeah we
just always
like i grew up different like
cooking for my when my mom cooked it
meant something special was going on
because we went out to eat all the time
yep so that's why when i would go to
people's houses when i was a kid and
their parents were cooking i always
thought like oh man there's something
special going on but i didn't realize
whose birthday is it yeah yeah i didn't
realize that's how it is people did it
yeah they did because they didn't they
couldn't afford to like you know you
know what i mean so it's like
so that was like a i grew up different
that way so now cooking is still it
feels special to me and stevie your
family would all get together and do the
turkey yeah yeah we we eat koreans eat
turkey right chin every year and your
mom
[ __ ] all the kids come over here
aunts uncles family
have football on or no i don't know well
i'm not too bad i'm my family's fault
wow oh no big into it yeah what did you
guys have on unreal oh they had the
karaoke going on
[Applause]
you know what i mean you're just an
uptown girl yeah what was that
accidentally
for some reason no matter how thick the
accent is they sing in perfect english
yeah
hey that's like deletes in your videos
what's going on here i don't like what's
going on here and chin you need to back
this up no that was a compliment that's
a cool that was a compliment yeah but
the karaoke yeah they sing perfect or it
sounds like perfect [ __ ] english yeah
that sounds funny
let's cut that out you think yeah dude
i'm telling you go to wii spot be a king
king interesting
dude i tell theo dude if you're feeling
down why can't that wease bother your
dick out dude
rub it down the parking lot walk in
there man
[Laughter]
yo what's up guys uh bobby lee's fat
cousin here vincent from arizona with a
quick question and a bit of a debate
club foreign i'm actually wearing my
iron mike tyson
uh christmas sweater here
obviously i'm trying to figure out
gender right i do the same i'm not
kidding
um iron michael chandler
and justin gaichi duke it out one of the
best fights that i've seen in a long
time most exciting rather but the whole
card was great uh question for you guys
is
what is the best the greatest most
exciting
um
most memorable sporting event you guys
have ever
experienced um
i i would just love to know from from
everybody you know obviously we got a
little bit of a different background
from each of you guys but uh thank you
guys for what you guys are doing um much
love
plus buzz young man go ahead guys let's
kick this off
i think the most memorable sporting
event i can remember being at was the
mike tyson
spinx fight oh michael spinks yeah cause
i was uh at about i was at a friend's
house in the 80s it was yeah it was a
huge deal it was a huge deal everybody
was talking about it and i'll never
forget it because it was like this the
fight started okay the fight started and
i went like this to reach for some chips
you're [ __ ] up when i came back up the
fight was over yeah it was that fast
bro people are so mad they complained
and asked for their money back the fight
was overwhelming
it was like 90 seconds he beat the [ __ ]
out of him he it was afro yeah it was
done it was done and i remember that so
distinctly being like yes here we go and
leaning down to get some some chips yeah
you [ __ ] up
and i came back up everybody was like
wow and i was like what happened and
there was no dvr back then that was it
you had to see a replay no replay and
they didn't show replays is this it this
is the this is it mm-hmm you don't put
the sound on people yeah yeah this is
great yeah this is this is
so i'm sitting there like here we go
guys here we go how old are you
stevie and brendan announced the match
uh mike tyson just i mean literally just
discussing so aggressive so now i'm
thinking here we go and then remember
this is like the first real test for
tyson i took right hook like this was
like the first big test for tyson just
mopped the floor no he's already beat no
he'd already beaten some people up oh
that was a legal kind of
hit right there and then we've got 11
rounds so a lot of stories we can get
into tonight uh can't wait to talk about
it all night
yeah you know what i mean
is this in where's this side is this
square garden just oh
he heard him right there with that left
before that dude donald trump's been
relevant for [ __ ] ever yeah
no this isn't the one it's almost over
the one you're talking about is the guy
has an afro no no they got off the floor
he
was no no this is the one it was just oh
that left oh no he heard him he hurt me
too to the body and yeah that was 90
seconds oh that's the one this is the
one tyson on those short shorts yeah man
but i'm telling you like you know the
fight starts and you go okay they're not
they're excited you're they're still
like they're doing this thing yeah
you're just kind of like all right oh
he's done oh that's probably when you
reach for the chips yeah yeah
he just told him like okay i'm good to
go well you're like oh this is fine let
me get some of that pizza that's exactly
it yeah you think okay all right he's
gonna get it is that queso off [ __ ]
that's what happened
that happened what happened that
happened
but
but i think
i think
that guy
in that first
60 seconds he was like i don't want none
of this no he's like that's not
snowflake that's not something i check
it out he was like i don't want none of
this no one did and then when he got hit
he went he was like i'm done yeah [ __ ]
this i i got paid already let me go out
i'm out stevie what's yours i can't
think i didn't really i don't really
can't remember like a live sporting
event i can't i really can't no
wrestling matches nothing yeah you know
what no you're seeing bob russell i
think most memorable yeah he took he
takes some sworn events though yeah
i went to overtime with this kid
and i remember it was tied up and they
went back to the circle and bob did like
a bruce lee no no the other guy tried to
like psych him out and was he a white
guy no he's an asian guy okay so he got
it she was like and then and then bob
blew him a kiss he went
and bob went down and picked him up
double legged them and that's i was so
proud that's kind of dope oh i'll give
you that yeah let's take another little
break from chatting about pumpkin pie
with the boys at king of the sting
because you need some good food man the
holidays are here you don't feel like
cooking you've been cooking you got
hanukkah christmas thanksgiving you've
been cooking that's where grubhub comes
in to play for you you need a little
break man maybe you're working hard from
home maybe you got kids you don't feel
like cooking grubhub works hard to serve
restaurants so they can work hard to
serve you that's right and today
grubhub's doing a little extra
for the fam at panera get free delivery
perk on your first order of panera for
for 15 or more that's right order
through grubhub app or online grubhub we
serve restaurants it's thanksgiving man
you got turkey you got pumpkin pie and
you got football that's right it's
thanksgiving and nothing says i'm
american like watching some football and
you do it with draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl and turkey day they got a no-brainer
you don't want to miss new customers can
bet just one freaking dollar on any
thanksgiving nfl game and win 100 in
free bets if either team scores a point
but you got uh you got chicago detroit
so hopefully they score some points the
worst game but bet on it makes so much
better get drunk and eat pumpkin pie and
bet on it if sportsbook isn't available
in your state you can still get in on
the thanksgiving nfl action make your
first deposit you can play free for
millions with draftkings daily fantasy
football contests draftkings is safe
secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want man download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
kats bet just one dollar on any
thanksgiving nfl game and win 100 and
free bets if either team scores a point
that's promo code kats this thanksgiving
at draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nfl must
be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call one eight hundred gambler that's
exporting it man some green bay packers
[ __ ] some varve [ __ ] absolutely bavarva
2003 his dad died yeah and then the
first game after that was monday night
in oakland and he had like the best game
ever at 300 he went off
399 yards and four touchdowns and then
the next week for christmas i got
tickets from my grandma uh to the last
game of the season last week god shout
out to grandma yeah and i went with her
and her boyfriend del cal shout out del
cal made rest in peace and we went to
the game he died at the game no no no
game game was game was awesome we went
to
uh brett favre's steakhouse in the
morning at tailgate and then they
weren't supposed to make the playoffs
because the vikings were going to win
and even if we wanted what year is this
2003. so that's when they dante
culpepper randy moss they were lit as
[ __ ] yeah yeah and uh
robert smith robert that was a little
earlier but either way
if the vikings won we weren't going to
make the playoffs so it didn't really
matter so even though we were winning
the crowd was like kind of down but then
they announced like the arizona
cardinals won on hail mary and then we
won so it put us in the playoffs and the
place went crazy
it was the first home game after brett
favre's dad died so it was like really
emotional and it was [ __ ] the [ __ ]
and then damn that story's better than
stevie's and then the next
dude
yeah we needed bobby to die
yeah and then the next week they played
in the playoffs against matt hasselbeck
and it was overtime and house buck was
like we want the ball and we're going to
score and he threw a pick six and we
went hilarious that was against the
seahawks yeah and then they lost to the
philadelphia eagles on 4th and 26th but
good year good year great yeah great
memory chin go ahead chin does that have
to be something that i was at or
something i just watched no yes let me
watch
so let me just throw this in though so i
was actually at the miesha tate ronda
rousey ufc fight
the second one we were there live it was
incredible but the one i saw on tv was
and i didn't even expect this to be
great i just i don't like it's not a
huge deal but cub swanson and korean
superboy oh that's my god
he's not even doing that anymore yeah a
different guy yeah korean super boy
here's a uh choi
what weight clash okay excuse me one
forty-five what do you know how that's
different again now
so it's like
yeah stun gun
yeah he was at 10 times fast
he was a monster so dum yum kim is
different from
stun gun
hold on a second because i want to get
that one with rice can we get this one
yeah that's racist
[Applause]
thing is still kyle dressed as a native
american yeah yeah
still number one all right so you have
something that you've been holding on to
no not really it's
your turn to i have so many i don't know
your last fight
probably broncos super bowl right
broncos subaru they were so good and
they were good for so long with like
john elway and trail davis they gave us
you know what i mean like what's a
memory uh
i remember when i thought i could do mma
when i uh i was in college and uh i
convinced all my roommates because you
know everyone's broke in college and
fedor was fighting crow cop and i we all
pitched in for the pay-per-view yeah and
i remember watching and i remember we
were like drunk i was like i bet you i
could beat those guys like get the [ __ ]
out of here seven years later i beat
croco that's pretty cool that is cool
yeah see those are the kind of things
like sports like
you know what i remember even a greater
memory is the first time i saw michael
jordan play
and i remember the game too i wasn't
really into basketball but it was the
playoffs and it was the bills bulls
versus the celtics and i'm watching the
game just because i had it on you know
and they announced it just michael
jordan michael jordan michael jordan and
i was like and then i was like yeah at
63 and i was like what god damn who's
this guy you know and he was just
murdering the celtics and after that i
was like wow i i started watching
basketball and wanting to play
basketball because of that game yeah
listen in colorado we've had some great
times i remember when i was a kid right
i played at unc colorado so i grew up
wanting to be a buffalo and when um
cordell stewart the miracle in michigan
they're playing at michigan he threw the
hail mary to uh westbrook and he caught
it my dad was holding my brother and
threw him into the fan on accident
remember that
yeah i remember that it's intense i
remember uh randy couture it was the
biggest live gate at the time not
anymore i think uh uh izzy otasanya beat
them out in new zealand but at the time
was the biggest live gate ever it was in
toronto and gsp was fighting jake
shields and then randy couture and
little machido i think was co-main event
on that
and i was there doing guest appearances
for the ufc and i was walking through
the hallway on friday night the fight
was on saturday and one of randy couture
jitsu coaches neil magnussen was a good
buddy of mine and he goes hey we need
you to help out with randy for his last
practice and i was like going to get
bears and meet girls or some [ __ ] i was
like ah he's like dude get your ass
there i'm like [ __ ] it we're in the
locker room no we're in the hotel oh so
he's like go get your [ __ ] i'm like all
right i go get my [ __ ] canceled all my
other stuff
get all my [ __ ] we jump in these hummers
and randy couture had uh he had the
extreme couture gyms in toronto so we go
there and he's uh i've never seen a dude
train like that he went like five hard
rounds like
hard and they're like we need you to
mimic leo machida i'm like what the [ __ ]
which
i was like all right he's got a karate
dude and so i'm like
holding pad for randy couture who i
don't know that well i'm like calling
pads as a south paw like little machida
and he misses the pad and hit me right
in the [ __ ] face
and i just remember going so hard so the
next night i'm at the fights i'm sitting
kate's side i'm like oh randy's about to
[ __ ] this dude up
within a minute [ __ ] front kick right
to the face knocked his kick tooth out i
remember that
randy couture retired yeah i remember
that one
yeah responsible a little bit no that's
not your responsibility
yeah i feel responsible also they should
be responsible for putting a guy who
doesn't mimic leo no one can no one can
mimic him he has his own style there was
other guys around the hotel probably do
it better see this is the thing about
fighting i just i never get i don't like
it i just like you know it's just too
violent for me but i remember like all
the ronda rousey hype
you know yeah yeah it was like it was
like high pipe and i was like wow what's
going on the holly holm and i just don't
like seeing women fight that's just me
you know i just feel nothing wrong with
that you know what i mean grow up with
it yeah i think i think a lot of people
feel that way it was just like but but
like i think they even feel that way you
know what i'm saying it's a little bit
different now like now you watch them
with like certain women fight like rose
or you know even misha at this point you
watch her uh young jun check and like
holy [ __ ] amanda paige van zandt amanda
nunez i don't like seeing anybody fight
but in particular
you watch chef jenkins
when that chick beat up ronda rousey i
was like which one
i was like what are we doing like
because the height was so like the kick
was pretty challenging
and then you would wish she looked
afterwards i was like why would you ever
want to hear that again
yeah i hear you didn't she retire after
that fight no she came back and fought a
man in the news yeah
it went even worse no yeah that one you
definitely don't want but i think she
might have been thinking about that i
think after you get
you you believe the hype don't get me
started there's a number of things that
went down i'm saying you believe that
but after you get but also dana was like
she's the mike tyson
no she's a jiu jitsu specialist so you
got her fall in love with her striking
then you're putting her against
world-class strikers and then she's
thinking she's the mike tyson like it
was the perfect storm to get her [ __ ]
up right
head movement yeah cause that's because
that holly holmes that's her name right
she's a world-class kid first of all
when i
when i i'm not into fighting but i
remember seeing that and when they got
into the ring my first thought novice no
no nothing about it i was like that big
girl was going to beat the [ __ ] out of
this little taller yeah
no that's just my thought but those like
there's no way this little chick is
going to beat this big chick don't get
twisted though ronda was a [ __ ] beast
no i get that
but the way that other one was just just
dipping so when they even started moving
it's just obviously bad it didn't look
like she was gonna ever be able to beat
her it caught up with her yeah kind of
right i don't know striking she needed
to work on her
i wanted to correct my sports story
kasuji sakaraba oh against kazushi just
all the gracie i just remember seeing
that scene fujita what was that like
fujita too yeah no i like sakuraba it's
like growling yeah because it was like
he was like doing tumble he had his own
style he was a beast yeah so he broke
his arm
yeah he be one he broke he refused to
tap out uh hands up kenzo he broke
enzo's uh
that sounds terrible do you remember the
kimura he did yeah
gracie's don't talk
how about this guys you guys don't even
remember this you're gonna be able to
look this up i remember watching this i
was a kid and glow was on
the gorgeous ladies of wrestling
and this chick broke her arm on live tv
and that's when you realized that they
played it up and then they played it up
like well i can't believe that this
happened
and they act like they did it on purpose
but of course it was obviously in the
but the chick really it was real the
gorgeous ladies of wrestling was real it
lasted for i don't know how long it
lasted it was real yeah yeah but it was
it was real fake oh kills it was like
wwf is he wearing big wwe fan and [ __ ]
in there like girls like i grew up like
big like
remember the british bulldogs remember
yokozuna
and remember his like like where the the
his thong went up his ass was all brown
remember that remember
that ricky the dragon he was so boring
i i like the undertaker i remember i was
such a that's later i was such a macho
man randy savage yeah yeah we're www.50.
i remember i was a macho man randy
savage fan
i would fall and i didn't want to and
then i would just go macho man macho man
uh
sporting event my uncle who's like my
hero and who passed away rest in peace
but he never saw me playing a game and
then he flew out to colorado when i when
we played uh kansas and he flew out to
boulder i was playing for university
colorado and we played the kansas
jayhawks and it was like we were down
like six points it was like third
quarter it wasn't going well i was on
the punt return team and i blocked the
punt and we returned it for a touchdown
and then we beat the [ __ ] out of them
but that was like my best game i've ever
played and my uncles in the stands
that's why you were on special teams at
that time especially fullback i played
offense and special teams oh wow it was
like special team captain so you were
like you were doing a lot of blocking
yeah man that's just full contact buster
wedgebuster it was a nightmare yeah i'm
sorry i'm i'm sure that was more violent
than ufc yo way more isn't that crazy
wait not even close not even close
because every single play i'm running
for 50 yards as fast as i can running
another human being yeah oh it's way
dangerous nightmare yeah they outlawed
wedge wedges now you can't do that on
kickoffs like what's a wet nose i don't
know the terminology explain that to me
when you kick it off the person who gets
the ball in front of them four guys will
basically almost it's a wall of human
flesh and then there's there's these
kamikaze guys that run and break the
wedge so the other guys can get in there
and tackle the player i was the kamikaze
guy that would break the web nightmare
and i was like known for it
how would you do that though like you
put your shoulder into it like head
shoulder whatever it takes that's what
they're saying that they they believe
that there's concussions on every single
play on the offensive
close and then i remember no like
they're just always there that's where
the most things by far by far and then
the thing is is on monday at the time
like we didn't know about ct and stuff
like that at the time they would like
highlight like oh look at shaw blow up
this guy and i'm like dude my [ __ ]
head's ringing man yeah he's like oh you
got your bell wrong and they like laugh
i'm like i was on adam ruins everything
and that particular episode was about
the the football
about like just trash and football and
about like how all of this violence that
like that you know
that goes on every single play that they
don't even talk about like like as as a
public viewer we always think about like
a safety going on a a receiver going
over the middle and getting hit we think
that's the most violent thing
not even realizing that on the offensive
defensive line the amount of violence
that goes on every single play
i'd make this this con
comparison it's like
think about if you're watching a boxing
match and you see the right hands
everyone knows the right hand that
knocks it out but imagine every single
punch he's landing it's just a jab where
it's not huge but it's a jab every
single time that's landing in your face
that's offense defense every single time
it's not these huge
hits but that's why boxing's even more
violent than ufc right boxing's more
dangerous not more
there cheap tactics like fish hooking
someone or like football yeah and
football they're like cheap no not
really i think boxing's definitely worse
because in ufc if you get knocked down
if you're concussed
but in boxing they're like 10 seconds
and you can you're definitely out of it
but they're like you can cuss three
times yeah just seeing muhammad ali
later in his life
i just was like i was out on boxing i
just it was like one of those things i
was like yeah he just was like you know
i was like it has to be from the boxing
i think my thing is with uh boxing and
showtime would kill me first but i'm
leaving them in december but um with
boxing it's like you have young kids
show a young kid even like a teenager
boxing show them the bet show them
canelo fight monster absolute monster
knocks them out like 10th round whatever
show box fight then show them show them
justin get you michael chandler go which
one do you want to which one do you
prefer to watch
not a hundred out of 100 kids go i'm
gonna watch this [ __ ] ufc fight
that's real fighting it's boxing
to get young the young and they struggle
with it now it's an old man sport well
the problem with this is not or to me
like we want leagues
we want it we want it to be like here's
the boxing season we want to see a chart
that these guys are doing like five five
six fights and we it gets to a point
where it's like you can understand we
can understand it the best thing
and i want i want scoring after every
round i want to know where it is i want
to know where we are you get that every
single round
i want every single
rounds in boxing no i need to know like
imagine how it would change the fight if
you knew all right you got to knock this
guy out to win
or in in mma they're starting to do that
like cans denver just passed it the
problem with that and i i i had big john
on food truck and i argued that i'm like
dude open scoring what the [ __ ] are we
doing he so big john for you guys that
don't know big john mccarthy mccarthy
created the rules that the ufc lives by
every commission goes off his rules he
created he created i didn't know that
he's been it forever he created it and
he goes here's the problem with open
scoring it was let's say it's a
five-round fight and you're firing you
up four rounds and you look at the
scorecard and they flash it on the
screen before you go up for the fifth
round where do
end it that's what i'm saying it's over
but that but that but then you're taking
away the guy he has the possibility of
knocking that guy out yeah which makes
great fun
but then but then if the guy needs to
then that's what i'm saying then
let the score be known because now it's
about the other guy not getting knocked
out and this guy trying to knock him out
and we know i'm with you i'll be open
for it but big joke
is terrible because like 12 round fights
it's too long and they're like remember
that the first six rounds they feel each
other out and we're all bored well oscar
remember that oscar de la hoya fight he
was fighting again what was his big
rival uh
another latin guy um and they had this
great fight and i thought oscar de la
hoya
won that fight
but like there was a certain point in
the fight where he like let up because
he was like well i got this one let's
tell boxy look at that he lost the
fighter
that boxing stuff gets so crooked
that's why they don't want to put the
score out boxing's the most crooked
sport in the world yeah that's what i'm
saying put the score on so we can know
what's up look at canelo triple g you
know
the real boxing rule should be once you
up here once you're up like so if it's a
12-round fight once you're up six rounds
you only have one round left and the
other guy's got to knock you out you
know what i'm saying like it's like it's
like it's like when you're a kid when
you play 21 rule yeah if we're playing
you know just baseball outside we get up
21 nothing it's a it's
over done yeah it's a waste of time sure
mostly no no it was another was good it
was a latin guy was it fernando vargas
yeah
was good either vargas or it was another
one
yes
he won that fight oscar was tearing him
up i'm talking about congratulations
next thing you know last three rounds
and they gave they gave the fight to the
other guy i was like what thanks
pocahontas plus the judges is crazy i
was out on that that's why i was like
you know my eyes see something and
you're gonna take that away i'm out
all right good luck pitching a young kid
boxing these days here's ufc here's
boxing every kid i'm like dude [ __ ]
give me ufc ooh showtime's on the line
hold on a second
i'm already out
we have a sync my ink uh here from uh
some old guy is really excited about his
neck hat
oh hey what's up
what a surprise look who it is
oh no
oh no
he leveled up
he's hardcore now
he stepped it up didn't he he got
another one and it means something
does it a lot of people are asking is it
real and i always respond with well are
there too many revolving hosts on king
of the sting because theo's out of town
all the time
oh chris
ouch wow oh that hurt funniest guy in
the world hey brandon hey stevie weeby
and hey eric griffin um thanks doug i
just figured i'd stop by and show you
the new ink because uh not many people
have seen it i posted it on my instagram
but it came out good
show you on video i absolutely love it
anyway i hope things are going well
sink my ink or whatever you call it yeah
yeah you know what it is dude yeah it
looks directly you know what it is
yeah
that's that's that's different that's
the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever seen a grown
man do well what is it you're supposed
to have that tat already on and you get
into your 40s and you're like yeah well
what is this you don't get to 40 and
they have a damn tattoo i don't know
what it says yeah what does it say so
for the meaning of 40 i talked about
there's nothing worse than tattoos
what's it mean you're like oh my god
it's personal dude yeah he might as well
have been a [ __ ] stamp yeah for him
so uh 40 is a special number for him
because 40 is the amount of days when
his son was born his wife's birthday and
then also when him and his wife
it's there's all these coins
[ __ ] off yeah
they [ __ ] you [ __ ] him
you're trying to explain this boy this
is
make sure you play some sensitive ass
music when he's doing that all right
yeah he made some ceremonies
yeah
i just said that's his that's his
description
you have no tattoos huh no
no i'm not gonna get a tattoo over 40.
getting a tattoo over 40. sting it
i dig it i did
that gave me the motivation to get my
neck tattoo finally i've won one forever
oh you're gonna you're gonna let this
you're gonna you're gonna let this
[ __ ] kiss my boyfriend
not on my neck here i'd get on the back
of my neck though so you can't see oh
you're gonna get a neck [ __ ] stamp yeah
yeah
it's gonna hurt
i have already it's not a big deal well
chris like i don't get why you don't do
it i'm like because i already look like
a hell's angel dude like i'm trying to
sell tickets bro yeah i still have it i
still have a chance in hollywood you
know
i know
yeah us know he's never acting again no
he knows it i told brian i told brian i
go dude you have to worry about
hollywood just get tatted on the face
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i still got to get one of these
brian should get one that says old ass
man right on that forehead let's just
get ranks [ __ ] him yeah or he should
get always tired underneath his eyes no
you know what if you get a neck hat
you're going to look so much more like
mexican yeah now you already got a weird
i i need to check your dna i don't trust
that you're irish you're
no i'm english italian
but you know what i'm saying so you get
it's already got like a sort of ethnic
look trust me i know yeah i think i feel
like i just need to double down on it
cops already want to pull you over
yeah nervous like is that a mexican and
ferrari when they see the neck [ __ ]
they're gonna be like oh get him
well that's like my special super
self-conscious about my tattoos and i
was like man you think i should show my
tattoos and so i text all my boys i
should have text you because you've been
comedy for 100 years uh literally theo
chris everyone's like dude do you yeah
you have to make all your fans know you
have tattoos yeah yeah yeah yeah anybody
who does everything you're already a
guy's guy doing comedy anyways yeah it's
not like you're like some odd looking
guy like me like that's that you know
where it's about that stuff you already
everything you represent is that so you
just the pie is used i mean the special
is called the broiser that's from sand
yeah
yeah you're good yeah no i rocked them
i can't i want a neck tattoo i love
chris
don't do that
now i'm definitely doing it you should
be like ah do it dude and then i've been
like really bad guys i'm that guy you're
really oh my god you're that stubborn
i'm so in oh any good tattoo artist out
there hit me up i'll put it on the show
i got one he'll travel here and we could
do it on air i was just gonna say bobby
brother i know i know a dude oh shout
out to dresden
is he good though
bring his instagram up nick dresden mate
he goes by dresden yeah i know what
you're saying you don't want to be like
is that melted scissors yes no it's a
crane scissors
watch
uh yeah yeah yeah well jeremiah i'm
trying to get him to get a tattooed yeah
jeremiah goes look at that oh he's
[ __ ] good yeah i would do that he
could travel here is he in l.a he's yeah
he's a yeah he'll travel here he'll
bring the kit here yeah don't say kit
but yeah i'm down
as you got your neck for sure yeah and
actually
and i can drink it'd be great i'll take
some painkillers be great
we get real [ __ ] up on there no he
looks super skilled yeah that's him i'm
never gonna okay i was like yeah he
looks like a snowboarder so nick we're
on the same stream
at your age though yeah what would i get
you know look at my i'm hairy get
something for your girl yeah that here's
distraction she'd love that you're super
hairy yeah yeah hairy chest and [ __ ] in
background let's see let's see yeah
shoulders and [ __ ] like andre lasky no
no no it's not crazy but like i do have
weird patches of hair yeah on your back
you got that duck tail down the the by
the [ __ ] yeah like right above my
butthole yeah yeah
it's a duck tape like a [ __ ] yarmulke
same
nick's hair
and i'm getting those random
pop-ups all over dude i gotta like
someone so when i'm shaving i gotta go
like this i gotta go
what about down here what's the hair
looking like downstairs oh you got a
bush
can't sting that
younger so she probably wants your [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah she's just like you know
shout out manscape it's so hard to shave
though because like i i literally have
hairs like you know their hairs are like
what's this people don't realize their
hairs are actually on your dick too you
know what i'm saying there's hair yeah
some hair on my shaft yeah it's really
weird but i shaved it down
jake you have a hair yeah on your penis
sorry that you're the you have no hair
on your body since you were
yeah
which is actually time to stamp that
definitely time this is another time
that's a good thing
did you see that time stamp picture that
right here
you should get a hair on your nuts i i
understand the nut hair but on your dick
now i have a few stragglers on my shaft
the shaft yeah it's on the shoulder
which part is the shaft
not the tip trump dog the trunk
yeah what you hold on to little hairs
growing out of the shaft yeah let's
shave those off it's always bigger okay
hey uh stevie real quick chin's not
circumcised are you no i'm standing
upside down yeah oh really you're born
here
like a different show my girl didn't
even know i was uh wasn't circumcised
she thought it was damn dog you know how
to say different shows
it's not like that's what he's always
like
it's not like on nbc and cbs it's not
like we're just kidding
just like the way you would wash your
dick i washed my dick the same way
you pull the hood back and then wash it
i mean you say pull it back it's just
like probably barely like this like
probably it's cheesy no no no does it
get cheese oh they don't get cheesy if
you don't wash it
nick you don't have an anteater no no i
feel for some reason
he's from wisconsin they don't know what
they don't want anybody they don't want
any kind of ethnicity over there yeah
they don't want to appreciate that
i feel like nick kind of
i feel like nick had an anteater with a
beard
like nick's anteater has a goatee yeah
when he pulls it back it's just a bush
big mike what are you working with you
got a anteater on you i do you do yeah
oh you do you want to tell him who big
mike is yeah yeah big big mike uh worked
out with us at zoo culture this morning
he won the fan contest to work out with
the crew chapelle
shout out to big boys where is that jim
zoo it's off the desoto in woodland
hills oh you guys worked out yeah big
mike's strong yeah
you'll see it on the vlog i reach i go
for a pr uh a personal best i know i
tried to bench 430 i didn't get it
jesus christ a lot of weight man i did
420. when are you gonna ever need that
[Laughter]
we'll see you dude you know the world's
crazy like you're gonna be outside ralph
so somebody's gonna be like oh dude i
got a 430 pounds of
can you help me with this you're like
you said that sure you can't
you say that though but when i passed
that accident that kid needed help out
of the car your boy
exactly open the open the car door yeah
okay man
uh but stevie could probably do that
because they're adrenaline you know it's
like a mom lifting a car yeah child
i don't i should but i don't i don't
know how much i could bench you're
asking mark a bunch of questions barely
i'm barely hitting these push-ups you
know what i'm saying
uh this guy's got a camera for us
what's up rat king
lord brennan
thank you
for y'all
uh when chicks call you
daddy
love it yeah it's kind of weird right
i feel like you
like it
well it's because you're dating a latina
right yeah yeah i'm married to one as
well yeah good luck bud but when they
call you papi no same [ __ ]
daddy nothing better i think poppy
sounds a little better than daddy
but uh well the way you said i mean i
think what you all think
and hey
with your dick out for this
how do you know
i knew he was fishing
yeah that's awesome oh this guy's face
where's the ass yeah he's fish she's
like nashville or something oh [ __ ]
oh damn you have the flippers on the
tubing
wouldn't that scare the fish away chin
no i mean you're slow
hey you guys are out of your mind if you
don't think you're it's called daddy
around the house you're an older dude
yeah yeah yeah we're good oh daddy she
doesn't do that really yeah that's not
her thing that's disappointing but i
have been called that
pre
he was like you're going to be naked
tonight and i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says
boner confirmed
yes
but she's saying that to a dude that's
not really that yeah so that's why
machine guns what do you mean
yeah machine gun kelly is a young dude
younger than her right younger than her
daddy's like a sexy like you know what i
mean it's like no one likes to be called
dad in there oh i know i get this all
the time when i'm at shows and the girl
girls are taking a picture
i get that you know you dad hey daddy
yeah they do that at your shop
bananas they don't they really do that
yeah
all the time now stephanie stevie
i love it nobody's calling me dad
why no time scam no stevie don't give
off the daddy vibes never has
i feel like they don't want to crave
a diaper but i don't think
out of anybody he don't give off daddy
vibes kyle you get called daddy probably
not smaller
i feel like
it's the beard going for me you know the
only thing i have going for me is
between my legs so that that produces
the daddy oh you got a dick on you yeah
yeah do you know if you do you got that
ohio dude that's the only thing oh you
got a good one yeah
congratulations you got a louisville
slugger down there yeah you got wow
down there yeah i think it's a short
just a short person thing you know god
gave me that and that's really all he
gave me is it thick or long uh
it's both really that's both check it
out it's like you're ready
to stop
yeah look
nick you you dig
megan foxy say it to me i've never dated
a megan fox i don't know you've never
had a girl call you daddy uh you'll
start living bubba and you're single but
look i've worked up with latinas and
they say poppy that's like he said
that's a little more palatable for me i
think kyle might be it's because you
grew up without a dad
was that too dark it really wasn't
too much i never thought about time
now that's why you don't like it
what does poppy mean what is that
that's that's latin for her dad what's k
rico
oh
i don't know that sounds nice when you
say yeah i'll [ __ ] you right now i see
it in videos
i don't know
do you know what that means
let's go let's wrap it up here
vpnexpress.com
promo code shop uh so that's all we got
uh we're gonna end uh we won't watch
them together but a montage of some king
and a sting fan saying what they're
thankful for let's go out saying what
we're thinking
i i'll say you know what i'm thankful
for being a part of king and sting yeah
me too you know what i'm just gonna be
in here i'm thinking oh i have a roof
over my head i'm thankful that i could
eat every day just the basics yeah yeah
his hot plate essentials you know she's
thankful for that really nice air
conditioning in the bathroom
i mean i'm thankful for you guys man
because you know with king of sting and
i told theo this for king the scene you
know
fans know what's up obviously you know
theo living in nashville makes it tough
for him to get back here all the time so
we've had rotating guests and
you know i have to tell theo i'm like it
sucks for me dude like i want to do a
show with consistent you know people
like i don't want a new guest every time
like i don't mind doing it's what i do
i've been in podcast so long i don't
mind doing it but also like i want some
regular [ __ ] hosts man and then when
you guys came in
it just you know it just clicked and
made so much easier so i'm super
thankful for you guys chin nick
big mike
kyle big dick christian christian
meatball who passed away but uh yeah the
whole squad man you know i think for
theo you know he does his best to get
here it's a beast man you know he's
flown to nashville like for him to come
back all the time it's tough man how
long was that flight dude almost four
hours man i'm thankful everyone come out
to everett this saturday everett
washington everett theater one night one
show only that's everett washington 30
minutes outside seattle to theater that
[ __ ] was almost sold out come on out
few tickets are left and then bringing
the new years with your thick friend
here in this weird cowboy hat the uh
pilgrim fuckboy here i will be in fort
lauderdale dania improv uh december 30th
through january 1st new new new one the
first headliner there so whole squad's
going out there it's the uh bringing the
new year with your thick friend here
that's it man and then also uh thick boy
uh restocks the store uh friday morning
at thickboy.com nine a.m black friday be
20 off and also we'll restock in all the
camo workout gear and some jerseys so if
you missed out now's your chance they're
gonna go fast yeah i'm in town i'm in
town this week i'm in la this week so
you can comedy store laugh factory those
places and then um
i gonna be in tempe improv in a couple
weeks
i'm also doing a one night at flappers
okay lapras is great yeah best food one
night
yeah well so i'm doing that like i think
it's like a thursday night the 9th i
think that's what it is december
december 9th i got one friday yeah yeah
i think it's a thursday i've got room
for your boy scissor bros live january
8th
uh in jeffersonville pennsylvania wow
we're doing a live uh podcasting event
we're doing a write out there what's
going on we're doing a live podcasting
event there good for you look at steve's
getting out here
y'all stephen happy thanksgiving we love
you guys eat some stuff in pecan pie for
your boy here
[Music]
we go
too yeah you know how we do it so just
tune in for the laughs theo said that he
was on his way but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
parkway
night only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric
[Music]
he still need everything thick thick
they still got the bees and the trap
trapping still the king in the sting so
quit asking
if you know then you know it's a cat's
thing ball and chain hair swang
[Music]
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan do2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
what is up king of scene crew i'm here
to tell you what i'm thankful for my
name is andre from oklahoma um
i'm thankful for a couple things uh one
definitely my girlfriend
she's done a lot for me in the year
going on a year and a half that we've
been together so i'm definitely thankful
for her um
obviously thankful for family because
without family where would you be you
know they help you whenever you need
help stuff like that and then i'm
thankful for like podcasts if we're
being honest with ourselves you know
podcasts really help you get through the
day they make the day fly by and you
really grow a bond with the people that
you listen to so happy thanksgiving to
y'all guys that king and the sting crew
bless you all
yo what up king of the stink fam it's
your boy travis coming out of eugene
oregon uh just want to hit you guys up
and let you know what i'm thankful for
you know i got the obvious like a roof
over my head good food to eat friends
family but it's not really about us is
it i spoke with a native man the other
day i sat down and i asked him how he
felt about thanksgiving
he looked me dead in the eyes and he
said brother
this is how it went down
years ago they tried to
years ago they tried to
ah [ __ ] it man happy thanksgiving guys i
love you all keep up the good work slang
slang drugs drugs king and they're sting
my name is adam i'm from the uk
i'm looking at myself and my bald head
rather than the camera right now
i just wanted to send this video to say
that i am grateful for my sobriety i
haven't smoked in over a year and two
months three months almost i haven't uh
drunk in in over
near enough two years i think
um and i am grateful
for all of the things that you guys do
with your online content in the creation
of a
a community of sorts
so thank you very much to all you
podcasting comedians and happy new year
and merry christmas in the wrong order
hello theo hello brendan
happy thanksgiving
i'm kidding
nintendo
anyway five things i am thankful for
this year are one as always my mom for
raising me by herself
two the shipping container my parents
met on to make me
three stevie weeby's appearances on king
of the sting hilarious
four my esl teachers for teaching me
english
five
uh i made a new friend at church who
makes these for me
happy thanksgiving
hey bubbas happy thanksgiving
this year has been crazy a lot of ups a
lot of downs
um
i'm sitting at 2 23 from 451
you know your boy
i just wanted to give a special
happy thanksgiving shout out very
thankful to my boy brandon to my boy
kyle christian
to my boy nick to my boy theo eric and
even stevie even though he beat my ass
i'm so thankful for you all thank you
guys for being in my life being a friend
and just
literally making my dreams come true
i couldn't ask for anything more ever i
feel like i am accomplished in life
i love you guys happy thanksgiving get
some more [ __ ] turkey
yeah